all right tiffany
yeah hi hi
[Music]
where are you from originally i'm from
penrose city you're homeless right now
mm-hmm how long you been homeless
recently i got our county like two days
ago so it's been two days again my
second round being homeless
you got where on my second run being
homeless
okay yeah i did five months in county oh
for what uh commercial burglary
oh is that right yeah and that's the
first time you've been to
prison or jail no it's the third like
third time considering being in the
county like after 18
and what else the teenager i was always
coming in and out
but so so you've been in jail three
times like four times
yeah and what for all the same stuff
yeah it's all the same case
how old are you um
[Music]
right now i'm 21 21 yeah
um tell me about your childhood what
your childhood
um as a childhood i always like to
i was very different than other kids um
[Music]
because i always just like to be like
instead of playing video games and like
being always like
doing something you know like
i don't know what are you saying average
kid will be doing obviously like in the
backyard like digging halls
um i don't know i was just i was
very i was outcast yeah
i mean not everyone's a conformist yeah
for sure
right
there's nothing wrong with being an
outcast
right and that's that's what i like
about myself you can be more
unique that way sometimes people don't
understand the things that i do and why
i do them but a lot of people don't
understand
yeah but there's actually a reason for
it do you consider yourself gay or
what do you consider yourself uh i
consider myself transgender
transgender yeah okay cool
and where would you like to see yourself
in five years i
see myself in five years in a mansion
and with a bunch of cars
in a [ __ ] mansion and
yeah in the hills what uh and what do
you do for money now
uh right now i'm prostituting you are
yeah so what kind of guys do you pick up
any types of guys um just depends like
um
i mean i pretty much do all types of
guys you know it's the money that i'm
after within a day
so it's like that's what i need to
survive so i mean
tell me a crazy story um i'm sure you've
got a few crazy stories
about prostituting
not really i haven't really been there
yet or something like that has happened
to me
where like somebody has hit me or
something but
um
that's good yeah there's a lot more to
for me to experience yeah
be careful out there um
how do your parents feel um about this
my mom like generally like she feels
like that's only wrong right now
so they feel like on her
like it's um i feel like on her it's
like
she feels um sad like for her because
because i'm doing this or like this like
lifetime lifestyle i chose but this is
what i like doing
excellent so at what age did it become
clear that this
was your path um probably when i was
like
18 18. so this is just a few years ago
do you have friends uh no no friends i
mean i have cool people i talk to here
and they're like around the tents and
um what is it
scared bro skid row yeah so but i i mean
i wouldn't call them friends i have a
boyfriend right now his name's jason
underwood
and recently we stopped he's uh
we recently stopped talking because um
um i just don't want to
be doing stuff behind his back and then
be talking to him you know because i
feel like that's going to make it even
worse
but i do love the man with a lot of my
all my heart and i have it right here
it was tattooed yeah so this is all
you're wearing tonight
and it's going to be cold right what are
you going to do um try to start
like what i do is pretty much i start
walking more and the more it gets walked
the more like i'm able to find someone
that's just strolling by and she's like
oh hey what's up
you know how much get in the car yeah
where will you sleep tonight or will you
sleep tonight
um you don't know yet i don't know yet
so drug wise
crystal meth is your drug of choice yeah
and
how long you've been doing that um
since i was 15 15 yeah that was that the
first time you did drugs
yeah i was first time i started using
drugs and then it was like around
16 17 18 19 so today i did
like a year sober in 2017
and yeah all right well thank you for
talking with me
yeah no problem good luck out there it's
crazy
daddy try to be safe all right
you